[Musica]
ho iniziato questo lavoro
partendo dalla riproduzione di un
particolare della nascita di Venere di
Sandro Botticelli in bianco e nero
che mi era stata donata da mio padre
ero molto piccola e sopra il mio letto
c'era pendeva proprio questo particolare
e la mattina così io ridisegnavo questa
forma continuamente con gli occhi
ridisegnato come se dovessi in qualche
modo ricostruirla
dall'altra parte dormiva mio fratello e
sopra al suo letto
c'era una una sciatocatana un wokizashi
giapponese una spada
mi sono sempre chiesta se le due cose
fossero in qualche modo è fossero
collegate
è una parte la bellezza
e tutte le estensioni di senso che essa
può avere
dall'altra parte un'altra bellezza
però in qualche modo
anche foriera di trauma
si cresce Io non tanto però
nel tempo mi sono dedicata agli studi di
storia dell'arte di teoria dell'arte
e attraverso questi studi ho incontrato
l'idea
della tattilità dell'occhio
un'idea che si deve a un grande scultore
teorico tedesco
Adolf of the Brand
e dedicai agli studi di cronologia
una branca della storia dell'arte Anzi
più correttamente della teoria dell'arte
l'iconologia da un grandissimo storico
dell'arte austriaco
fu definita una storia dell'arte per
ciechi
in un certo senso la sua espressione
certo non gentile forse all'apparenza
nascondeva una grande verità era un
espressione sincera
come può Venere come rappresentazione di
un'idea quindi non tanto è soltanto come
rappresentazione di un soggetto
mitologico come mitografia ma anche come
metafora della nascita e della rinascita
come può Venere nasce nascere e
rinascere tra sensi e intelletto
quando osserviamo questo capolavoro
quando ci rechiamo alle gallerie degli
Uffizi e lo vediamo dal vivo e ci
accorgiamo di molti dettagli o quando
così in un'ottica un po' stereotipata
con una con un assetto Che talvolta
rischia di diventare un po' come dire
presuntuoso
osserviamo Questa composizione
molte cose forse ci sfuggono
forse ci sfugge la posizione di questi
soggetti
il fatto che Venere sia posto al centro
della composizione Ma appena appena le
sue spalle
e ha una distanza non Chiara non
decifrabile
troviamo il gruppo degli zeri Zefiro
abbracciato a Glory Anzi più
correttamente Gloria abbracciata a
Zefiro in un abbraccio Amoroso Che
genera vita Claudio forse la brezza Aura
e un po' in posizione avanzata una delle
ore coloro che presiedono il mutamento
delle stagioni e in senso in un'ottica
metaforica alle trasformazioni
l'opera nasce nel
1482 85 nasce per una committenza
medicea certo non nasce per il grande
pubblico
nasce
secondo una idea aristocratica
dove coloro che coltivano
le cose migliori
avranno anche le
più difficili più grandi responsabilità
Dunque colui che governa
colui che ha il privilegio di una
appartenenza a un determinato ceto è
colui che deve distinguersi
ed è colui che deve conoscere la
filosofia deve avere amore per la
conoscenza anche per affrontare ciò che
sarà scomodo
agire
mi sono chiesta tante volte
sei veramente l'iconologia storia
dell'arte per ciechi non dovesse essere
applicata secondo una logica di
trasformazione della coscienza
dell'essere umano nell'atto della
fruizione o più correttamente
dell'interiorizzazione di un'opera
d'arte
perché un'opera d'arte ha il compito
principalmente di essere paradigma
conoscitivo
E dunque mi dedicai all'educazione
estetica delle persone non vedenti
accolta all'interno dell'Istituto dei
ciechi Francesco Cavazzi insieme ai miei
colleghi che lavoravano al mio fianco e
io a loro
ma incontrando anche tante difficoltà
non si può nascondere anche tanti tante
perplessità legittime
non dobbiamo usare applicare una ricerca
oppure se usiamo pensare a qualcosa che
diventa ricerca e la applichiamo
dobbiamo prepararci ad ogni scetticismo
e ad ogni Verifica anche cruda e fu così
fu così fino all'anno in cui
incontrai ricercatori giapponesi che
studiarono in maniera molto tecnica
questo metodo un metodo che deriva dalla
scuola panno Schiano dall'istituto Abby
warburg all'origine aveva sede in
Amburgo poi Con l'avvento del nazismo
fu trasferito a Londra e cominciai a
applicarmi
alla conversione del metodo
tripartitopanoscano ad uso didattico ad
uso delle persone cieche in modo
sistematico
possiamo rendere comprensibile a una
persona non vedente lo sguardo distante
dolcissimo ma lievemente malinconico
della Venere
forse possiamo
trasmettere ogni contenuto
legato alle fonti classiche
in un'ottica di erudizione
Ma c'è qualcosa di impalpabile che anche
Nella migliore delle traduzioni plastica
non può fino in fondo arrivare E allora
E allora facciamo i conti con il limite
con il limite con la potenzialità della
parola e della poesia
pittura poesis diceva Quinto Orazio
Flacco come in pittura così in poesia e
Una poesia può sostenere la cognizione
di una composizione pittorica come una
composizione pittorica può generare un
pensiero poetico immaginativo
poetica della manualità
La forza del fare l'azione
trasferire tanta impalpabile bellezza
pure percettibile al senso privilegiato
che è la vista
quando la vista Si assente magari dalla
nascita
quando si è necessario integrare i sensi
residui e tutti i giorni fare i conti
addirittura con una lenta perdita perché
non tutte le persone cioè che nascono
tali non tutte le persone cieche
diventano cieche per traumi
alcune diventano cieche lentamente
ed è lungo il cammino verso quella
direzione verso quella condizione che è
lutto che perdita
tutte le perdite tolgono qualcosa un
essere umano o le perdite possono
veramente diventare eroicamente una
possibilità
forse anche per riconfigurare meglio il
nostro essere
le fasi di modellazione di finitura di
un prototipo in argilla hanno anche
tanti aspetti tecnici che vorrei
raccontarvi
non possiamo tradurre un'opera d'arte in
modo sommario
così come un traduttore
professionista
Cerca l'equivalente estetico o Cerca
l'esatto valore semantico di una parola
in una lingua madre che dovrà essere
tradotta in un'altra
Così noi cerchiamo di tradurre la
pittura ad uso delle persone non vedenti
cercando l'equivalente estetico e lo
facciamo anche nella descrizione c'è una
grande tradizione di storici dell'arte
che ha sposato la causa dell'equivalente
estetico a partire da Roberto Longhi
può una traduzione monocroma priva di
colore
priva di quelli impalpabile atmosfera
che è appannaggio e che è pregio della
pittura arrivare Comunque condurre
all'emozione estetica forse sì
ma deve fare i conti con livelli che la
precedono
la percezione
la cognizione una razionalizzazione di
forme e contenuto composizioni linee di
forza aspetti tecnici della figurazione
l'estensione di senso la metafora
non potremo mai far vedere un vento
rendere percepibile
il vento che giunge dalle gote gonfie
insufflato da Zefiro e aura Clori
implica compiere gesti iconici
per lo stesso principio come potremmo
vedere
non basta collocare
uno strumento triplo didattico
in un museo
di altissimo pregio come le gallerie
della le gallerie degli Uffizi
per poter garantire la comprensione
perché ogni gesto tattile Ha un ritmo e
deve essere sostenuto da una parola
che ne conferma il senso
vediamo come
la fertilità
normalmente
nell'educazione estetica delle persone
con deficit o con disabilità visiva
è lenta ma non può essere monotona
non sempre i polpastrelli aderiscono
alle forme Talvolta è necessario
discostare i polpastrelli
dalle forme
Per far sì
che la persona non vedente avverta nel
gesto iconico un fenomeno meccanico
fisico come un galleggiamento o un peso
specifico di un corpo umano per quanto
idealizzato in un'ottica di filosofia
neoplatonica che comunque andrà spiegata
in una forma agganciata in modo
agganciato al dato sensibile affinché
qualsiasi discorso intorno all'immagine
qualsiasi iconologia argomentazioni
intorno all'immagine non risulti puro
verbalismo grande pericolo soprattutto
in presenza di disabilità visiva
e quindi possono questi gesti e queste
azioni e questo modo di Accarezzare le
forme in modo organizzato in qualche
modo razionalizzato condurre
all'emozione estetica e condurre anche
tecnicamente alla restituzione della
forma in quelli che sono laboratori di
modellazione che possono apparire per
così dire meno aulici meno poetici ma in
realtà vanno a costruire le strutture
del pensiero il pensiero visivo
attraverso il quale le persone non
vedenti agganciano le parole che
corrispondono al referenti reali
rappresentati dalle parole ma anche
rappresentati nelle immagini dotate di
valore estetico e un'immagine di valore
estetico serve davvero tanto a una
persona cieca o è per così dire un
intrattenimento e quasi in un certo
senso un lusso che non ci si può
permettere in quella che è una vita
pragmatica
l'educazione estetica serve
a compiere passaggi di stato dalla
realtà concreta
al concetto astratto
alla metafora
e dunque quegli studi di metodo che
furono condotti in Giappone avevano
proprio come scopo quello di indagare
quanto fosse legittimo il nostro lavoro
E fino a che punto potessimo portare
all'autonomia alle persone non vedenti
senza plagiarle
grave rischio infatti perché ogni gesto
iconico ogni analisi tecnica Ogni
passaggio dal concreto alla
prospettica come prospettiva Come forma
simbolica deve poi convergere per così
dire in una capacità di restituzione
nella possibilità di concretizzare
quella che noi definiamo pur
nell'inpermanenza delle cose della vita
Opus
[Applauso]